welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz today i'm very excited to
be joined by rory ferguson
who joined the recruitment industry in
the 1990s after serving as an army
officer
and over the last two decades rory has
led and grown multiple teams across
several brands
such as harvey nash the hydrogen group
lawrence harvey group petro plan and
more recently
rp international rory is extremely
passionate about successful leadership
in recruitment
and in the recent months has been
helping business owners maximize their
recovery and growth
potential by delivering executive
coaching performance mentoring
and strategic advice to recruitment
leaders and emerging talent
rory thanks for coming on the podcast
hisham wow what an intro i'm not sure
where i go from there but yeah thank you
very much good to um
to join you so thanks for asking me i'm
excited to
unpack the journey that you've been on
but where we always like to
to start is in in your opinion
what characteristics and traits do you
think make up a
highly successful recruitment consultant
wow um okay so
um the people that i've worked with
uh that have been most successful i
guess the most sort of the common
denominators are
they're massively goal driven okay and
it doesn't matter what that goal is
um you know when i joined it was all it
was all about the cash i think it's less
about that
now potentially but they need to be gold
driven um
some of the best people i've worked with
you know as an example some guy wanted
to set up a bar in southern spain at
some point now
you know i can use that there's
someone's motivation as long as they've
got that because
recruitment is great it's awesome
everyone loves a high five earning loads
of commission that's fantastic
and when it's bad it's really bad you
know it's it's uh it's tough
so you need that sense of a goal i think
to to bring you back in
and and and keep you focused in the bad
times as well as the good times
i think expertise is probably my next
piece so um
important to invest the time to to be a
credible expert in what you do
that helps with credibility it also
helps with your network
you know i think people always talk
about hard work that's almost a given
and i think in the early years there
aren't
many shortcuts so look if you've got a
goal
if you're prepared to be an expert if
you're prepared to put the hard miles in
um and if you're prepared to listen to
those around you and absorb
um and work to work to a process that uh
that is proven um then
that that's probably the ingredients
that make up that that i can think of
that that probably
make up the the best recruiters out
there right
so as i said you before we started this
i i haven't had
a ton of people from the the harvard
nash brand so
yeah i guess it'd be great if you could
just obviously you joined you joined
uh that company in 1994. i've just gone
on to be uh
sorry it's gone to be uh obviously yeah
a huge name in the recruiting industry
so i guess
before i start talking about yeah early
days for you in in recruitment
and right what what did that company
look like when you joined it
how big was it like i don't know what
was that
look massively massively different um i
mean i
joined i think it was uh i think it was
40 to 50 people when i joined
um we were we were not in an office in
covent garden
um and
i think a lot of that size and shape of
that business and how it then how i
then saw it grow was part of my
you know that generated my desire to
then go
try and go on similar journeys in in the
future actually um
it punched well above its weight i mean
i remember we were always trying to take
on the likes of michael page and and
companies like that
um it was a company that had real
a real sense of uh
i guess purpose um
and we felt we were on a journey you
know it was privately owned um
there were originally four owners of
that business but there were three that
really went on
and played an executive role within it
and it was great being part of that it
was a
it was an amazing journey i was i was an
i.t contract recruiter
uh into investment banking um and uh
yeah we felt we we genuinely felt at
that point that we could
we could be the we could be the best in
the market
yeah i love that and so just for context
you stayed there for
12 years before you left so i guess you
you're talking
yeah you're you're um you're talking a
bit about it there but
what i'm really curious about is
is is what the sort of and you're
talking about there in terms of you felt
like you had a per
purpose and they they had high standards
it seemed like so
from your point of view looking back
what do you think were the sort of free
non-negotiables of the sort of harvard
culture that everyone abided by do you
think that sort of really
what were the ingredients of that
culture you think that everyone followed
and bought into the
yeah gave it the sort of real recipe to
to become a great great business
yeah okay um
well we were really into brands you know
brands um
was massively important i mean one of
the one of the unique things about that
brand
certainly at that point was um
we were working uh we were working
executive search at a senior level
um so we had excellent profile um we had
the ear of decision makers within
within companies um so
there was always a big play on on
representing the brand appropriately
um good packaging i guess and everything
that we did was really important
uh the hard work was the second one we
were all grafting
um you know back back then
um you know everyone was putting a big
shift and i did
i remember my managers now and the guys
i sat with i can visualize it now
and you know i was doing probably a
couple of nights a week till nine
um researching mapping companies
uh so so hard work was a given
and i think it was a there was no there
was no
fixed sort of clever process there was
no kind of sophisticated way of working
as such but it was very success driven
so we really celebrated success um
and and there was quite a good team
attitude towards that
so um we
yeah we really we really celebrated the
success and the growth of the company
you know i think everyone
um you felt that everyone who is in that
business
we all even though we weren't we felt
like shareholders we felt like
you know we felt like we had a um you
know we were on that journey with the
owners
um those those are probably the three
things for me
it was it was a great journey to be a
part of them
yeah so i'm interested in that so let's
just
let's just sort of put a bit of a
magnifying glass on what that final
point that you just said because i feel
like
in especially over the last year i think
that that sort of purpose piece or like
me feeling like i'm
someone that's really playing for the
logo and that's really important for me
and the company logo that i play for is
really important to me which means that
when i'm feeling really down and it's
just me in my living room calling people
getting rejected
dealing with this sort of trials and
tribulations of being a recruiter but
this time i'm on my own
i haven't got the sort of culture to
soak up to pick me back up
yeah i guess you can draw on all your
experience here but i guess
i'm just really interested in that
because i think that's what
sets apart so good companies are great
companies right where you can actually
really get your people bought into like
being part of that journey
so guess what like i don't know how how
does that happen
or like how maybe where do people go
wrong or i don't know like how
can companies actually tap into that
because i don't know how many companies
actually successfully do that but
there's companies that come to mind
in the industry that i think it does
feel like all the team
are like so excited to be on this
journey and they're playing for the logo
i think that's that's really difficult
for
a lot of recruitment business owners to
to truly achieve so you clearly felt
that you're still speaking about
those days so so far um yeah you're
still speaking about it in that way so i
guess
i don't know what what comes up for you
when you think how how companies have
achieved that
or do achieve that um i
i would probably remember less of that
detail
from from harvey nash but i certainly
subsequently work with businesses
um that did it really well um
and um
i think the main thing the emphasis is
on on the leadership really
to set a vision
um or or yeah share a point on a map
that um represents that
where we're trying to get to i think i
think if you can get people on
on that journey um you know
however however good you are at a job
you know there's always a distinction
between skill and will will there's
always so much more powerful
you know and if you're able to get
people on a journey and they really
believe in you they believe in where
you're where you're trying to get to
and this this is in all walks of life
actually i definitely had this in the
army too at a very early age
if people buy into that sense of where
you're trying to get to
um you know you very quickly that's
unbeatable people get on the bus they
get on the journey and
that's where you unlock things like
discretionary effort so
you know you you've got a certain type
of individual
that is there because they have to be
you know they're doing the nine to five
whatever it is they're doing or they're
in recruitment terms it might be nine to
six or whatever they're doing their
calls they're doing what they have to
but as soon as you can unlock
discretionary effort it's the kind of
the day job plus
so yeah so it's the kind of the stuff
that they're going to do
in in addition you know and that that i
think is the secret source of a lot of
these companies that have
that have really nailed growth and
progression particularly over the last
five years
is that engagement piece how you get
people on the journey and how you get
everyone you know busting their guts
daily to
to make a difference yeah i love that
phrase discretionary effort i think that
that's yeah that's really interesting so
i guess
let's flip this then on
what where do you think people go wrong
and
sort of lead people not getting brought
into them so you've spoken about
yeah leadership and yeah having a vision
and these types of things what
what typically drives people the other
way and sort of yeah
pushes them in the way where they don't
buy into or typical things that
stop them from tapping into that
discretionary effort in
their teams yeah so so i
i think some of those things are as
you'd expect as sort of the direct
opposite of what we've talked about and
there's probably a couple of other
things as well
i know people get really disengaged
and i've seen this throughout actually
in my career where
i think in recruitment for middle
management which is which is potentially
the most important tier
in any business you know your middle
management
are the guys um who are the difference
between generating scale
and not and that and that through
performance and it's generating future
leaders as well
and when you've got a cohort at that
level that are just driving inputs as in
they're driving activity
but it doesn't connect to outputs
you know i think i think that's where
things start to fall down i think if
you're able to start with a goal
work out what your outputs are and then
relate your inputs to that in terms of
driving that activity and everything
then great but i think i think people
get exhausted
by focusing constantly on a short-term
goal so this is what we're trying to do
today this is what we're trying to do
this week they might look as far as the
month
i think if you can give people a sense
of reconnecting well
this is where we're trying to get to by
the half year guys and this is where
we're trying to get to by the end of the
year
you know even that that's still not a
massive
projection but at least you're taking
people's face out of the day-to-day
and you're reconnecting them with that
sense of purpose and why we're doing
that so i i think that's a fairly key
one people feeling
a sense of what they're doing is making
a difference to a bigger goal
yeah that's definitely one that's
certainly one thing
yeah it's interesting to say that
because having spoken to a lot of
recruitment managers and leaders over
the past couple of months
something that they've had to learn and
this has been quite common
i had to chat with someone today about
this and like we were talking about how
they've sort of learned
to get the best out of their team in the
sort of in the yeah
strange and different circumstances we
found ourselves in and yeah
the common thing that they've said is
that
in their meetings they don't talk about
numbers
they don't talk about the inputs i'm
talking about
they don't they learn to not maybe
before
in their reviews or monthly things they
would have been the main things they
would have focused on
like how many how many interviews you
got this month for how many
how many how many clients you agree
terms of in these things and actually
it seems like yeah that they're it's
learning that actually no we
need to not talk about that and talk
about how can i help you get to where
you need to
and like you said remind reminding them
this what you just said it's about look
this is
this is where we are today let's talk
about maybe the areas that we can
improve things that you did well
um let's let's talk let's use this time
to talk about where we're going
on this journey rather than yeah talk
about the kpis you missed with kpis that
you did here right
yeah i i think i think just to set some
context within that
um i would never i would never disregard
kpis or inputs okay they have a role to
play
um you know it's a bit like um lewis
hamilton going out and doing his um
practice laps or his qualification um
and you're saying we're not going to
give you any splits we're not going to
give you any segment times we're not you
know we're not going to give you any lap
times you so
you need you need something there to
ensure that you you're on track
you're going into exactly yeah but i
don't think
you want to have a disproportionate
focus on that is what i'm saying
um yeah i i think the key thing
is is if is if you can just you know
make it outcome orientated then
you know that that's the way ahead yeah
so i know we've ended up talking a bit
about leadership here but i'm
i'm interested to hear about sort of
rory the the recruits are right so
what i'm always interested in so you
spoke about harvard nash forty fifty
person company when you joined
and by the time you you left you yeah
join as a trainee but then progressed
to sort of leadership direct level
before you and left so
i guess what i'm always intrigued about
is the you're you're
you're in a very competitive environment
right not only with your competitors in
your market but competitive
internally right yeah so what what i
want to know
sort of in looking back like why why do
you think you was able to be
the person that got the promotion and
not your peers
like why was you the person that was
able to to yeah achieve the progression
that you wanted to and
and grab those opportunities internally
with both hands because
look i think a lot of people are a lot
of recruits that listen to this and the
real common
driver for people is progression right
in increase
so and i think sometimes what we always
talk about here is
this sort of learning that yeah you you
if you if you're really serious about it
then you you have to be accountable to
to getting it right and that goes more
than just delivering on your performance
and then expecting that your manager's
gonna go do you want this promotion or
do you want this right so i'm always
interested in that particularly in
environments which have ended up being
yeah extremely high standards you're in
a business
that would have grown so much so why do
you think he was able to
to progress and gain those promotions
rather than some of your peers
um
okay so i i i was
personally always hungry to progress
i i wanted to get on i i wanted to earn
cash
um and i think there were a few of us
that
uh i think back to that time where that
that was almost our sole
driver was you know um earning what we
could
um career progression probably came as a
result of that
um my
background as i guess in the army and
leading people probably helped just in
terms of a
from a confidence perspective and the
ability to get people on board with a
goal and a journey and try and motivate
and
and and get people moving so when i made
that move from being a consultant into
managing you know one person two people
then teams then
then several teams and divisions and
businesses
um that was probably a key part of it
i i genuinely don't recall at that time
there being any
particular sophistication in in terms of
my approach i didn't get any input
formal input into my leadership
development until late i think i became
like i'm still still absolutely a work
in progress here so
uh but but i had a step change in terms
of my ability
um you know probably after i left harvey
nash
the the the moving into a different
sector
um for example um
forces you to ask be much more
inquisitive ask more questions
not being an expert in something so you
can't use your market knowledge to sort
of paper over cracks
you know those are the kind of things
that really unlocked my potential
in terms of asking better questions
therefore being a better influencer
because i was listening more
better coaching um those were probably
the things that
probably had a far greater influence on
on me in terms of my progression and
then going on from there to do
bigger meatier roles like group md at
lawrence harvey and ceo and ceo and
things like that
um yeah i mean harvey harvey nash great
journey it was a long
it was a long time ago hisham so i'm
kind of picking my brains to give you
stuff of
real value um but it was it was really
about
really grafting um i i think the thing
that we always did i should have
mentioned this earlier that was drummed
into us
um was that there was a real difference
between being a recruitment consultant
and a recruitment agent
you know consultants consult and agents
transact
so we were always trying to seek uh
partnership wherever we could
and i think one of the challenges for
people in in this market particularly in
the uk right now i think it's slightly
different internationally
is that especially with the speed now
with increased technology and tools and
and the competition of on-site teams and
rpo
um you know it's a struggle sometimes to
distinguish between being a
transactional recruiter you know almost
becoming an administrator and actually
pulling your head out of that
and really influencing through being a
good consultant
yeah love that so let's dive into what
you just shared there because
this was actually one of the questions
that i wrote down on sort of preparation
for this and
it's something that came from a uh
recruiter and the question is
basically yeah it'd be interesting to
find out
around how you managed consultants in a
division where you hadn't worked before
as a consultant yeah okay so just
because i think that
yeah i think that's just so interesting
right so i think people listen to this
may find themselves in that position or
they may
have a leadership opportunity but it's
in an organization and then the market
they haven't sort of yeah worked in
before because
as you know typical route is if i'm a
tech recruiter construction recruiter
then i end up leading a construction
team or whatever right so
yeah yeah wouldn't it be great if you
could talk about some of those learnings
or how you had to adapt what you had to
learn the hard way
so look i would encourage anyone um who
who is making a career out of moving
into that leadership space
to try and work in a in a sector they're
not familiar with
um and and whereas
on paper it might seem quite daunting
because you're lacking things like
market knowledge and network credibility
actually what it really enhances is your
need to play to the strengths of other
people around you
um if i think as a leader if you always
feel you need to be
the best person in the room that that's
quite limiting
so one of the key learns for me was was
identifying okay well who are the key
players within the business um
you know what what do they know what
what can they help with if we're if
we're talking about new markets if we're
talking about
looking at existing markets that we're
in how can we challenge some of those
things so
so getting input from from the experts
around you is is key
um you go into a business like that
with zero assumption if i go if i if i
was to go straight into another actually
this this is a you know um an error on
my part for example when i made that
first move
from harvey nash into my first business
um
smaller business which was the jm group
um you know i went in there knowing
loads about technology so i was
i was making loads of assumptions about
the kind of markets we should be in and
stuff like that um actually
you know by going into a market that you
don't know you don't make those kinds of
assumptions you know you take time
you're really
invested in talking to clients spending
loads of time talking to clients about
what their needs are
what they see you know how the market's
going to unfold
yeah so playing to the strengths of
others i think is key on that
asking good questions um and
and relying on on your core kind of
management and leadership
experience just to get the best out of
that situation
you go through that journey yourself of
understanding more and becoming more of
an expert
um and that was a that was a really
really good few years for me personally
in terms of moving into a different
sector which also took me
internationally i've never worked the
international markets before so there
are a few things that are going on
different personalities moving into a
different business that that was
challenging as well
um so there was loads of stuff happening
um
but yeah look if you if you've got clear
purpose as we did
you know we really put the hammer down
at that time and became in my view
anyway of course i'm biased
but we were definitely in terms of the
leading specialist uh
recruiter in our space at that time you
know we were well up there across
europe middle east and africa um
i hope that helps i don't know if i've
answered no no that does no yeah no
that does i guess what what just came up
for me what i was interested
like since the two things so one
when you went into let's just yeah let's
just focus on maybe let's say the
hydrogen group for a second yeah when
you went into that organization
what did you make sure you didn't do
to get off on the bad foot because i
think i think this
i think that's what a lot of people are
worried about i think yeah yeah
no i think everyone's been in there
where yeah
i've i've been working at an
organization for a period of time they
hire a manager externally
and yeah they come in and yeah try and
sort of
let everyone know that they mean
business and they're they're they're the
leader or manager whatever you got i
mean so i guess i don't know yeah
looking back was there anything that you
completely avoided to make sure that
maybe i didn't fall into that
the stuff that i got uh it's definitely
stuff i got wrong
um and and
i think when i was hired by the ceo we
talked about
some of the challenges um
that we would have and i think the key
thing was that that was a successful
business
uh i was the first director level hire
into that business
um and so integration
my integration into that team was was
important and i
and i think i think that because they
they were all
you know good people and and and
were very welcoming to me so actually
that that worked quite well if i if i
made a mistake hashem it was
um i was all i think i was trying to
force i i was trying to make a
difference i was trying to
almost just to show them and justify my
seat at the table
i almost tried to do much too much too
quickly
by trying to make changes to things that
weren't necessarily broken
and i think actually to be fair the ceo
took me took me to one side and said
look
you've got you've got to focus on trying
to trying to understand before being
understood
so really get you know understand what
the good stuff is in a business so
you're not trying
to change the world you're not trying to
reinvent the wheel so understand what is
awesome about that business every
business will have it
every business will have that that bit
whatever it is or however small it is
doesn't matter that you can build on and
grow
rather just than just trying to bluster
in and go look at me i'm why do we do
this why don't we do that why don't we
do this and i think if i had my
time again certainly or anyone going
into that it would be look
definitely spend the time getting to
know your peer group and get really
clear on your expectations
so what does the first 90 days look like
what does the first year need to look
like
so everyone knows where you are you know
what success looks like etc but but
you know go in there don't assume that
you need to change the world in your
first month
you know understand ask good questions
understand what the good stuff is and
build on that
yeah love that okay and then the next
thing that is coming up for me because i
think this is probably something you've
had to learn but
or you've all you've dealt with in the
past so i've seen this in various places
sort of online forums and just
conversations that i have
like if you were to ask most recruiters
what was the main reason you left
your last agency or job right
there'll be a few different reasons but
one that would definitely be up there
top three i'd say is
poor leadership micromanagement
yeah yeah i'm just
like curious to to hear from you because
you should spend so much time in this
space
like why do you think leaders are
unaware or are they unaware that they're
micromanaging
yeah no i i think um i think that's a
really
really good point and um
uh it's definitely something as an
industry that i'd like to see us do
better
and and i think um a lot of managers
manage like that because they were
managed like that
and you almost need to break the cycle
and i i'm one of my hopes
is that um you know one of the good
things that hopefully can come out of
you know this this uh horrific 12
months that we've had and people working
from home is that
that may i think not just in recruitment
actually you hear a lot of leaders
that that prism has almost shifted to
being more outcome orientated than input
orientated
um so yeah i agree with that and i
i also think that you know managers
are trying to sometimes control every
single detail and almost do
almost do the job you know it's too
directive you know there's not enough
um you know coaching mentoring
delegation you know you get to a point
where
you've got to do it this way and i think
get people get
pretty sick of people trying to do their
job for them it's like kind of
buying a guard dog and barking yourself
why why would you do that you gotta you
know if you've made you've made the
investment
you've made the investment in someone so
so help them learn and let them get on
with it
if they graze their knee a few times
then great that's where your learning's
going to come from
so i do think there's plenty of
opportunity actually as i said earlier i
i think that mid tier of management
is is what leaders should be investing
in you know that that ultimately is
is what's going to turn people on or
turn people off you're either going to
make awesome consultants great future
leaders
or you're going to lose people out of
the business because of the way they're
being led but i i agree with you i think
that leadership piece is a is a big
reason why people leave companies
the other piece of course is just what
we've talked about already is around
engagement
you know do they believe do they believe
they're part of a journey
is the pain worthwhile yeah
so do you think those managers i know
you said it
maybe because they were managed that way
i'm i'm just like do you think
they're like consciously aware that i'm
i'm i'm micromanaging my team here
like is it i know there's so many
different nuances but
do you i don't know like do you think
that if i was to turn around to you and
go look look rory
let's say no sort of i've i've decided
to leave and then our sort of um
yeah leaving interview i go look i'm the
reason i'm needing is because i'm
micromanaged but do you think most
managers that micromanage would be
surprised
to hear that like do you think they're
actually aware that they're they're
micromanaging
well look firstly on that i want to be
clear on on what someone is
someone's definition of being
micromanaged is because
if your manager is showing an interest
in your stats and your inputs and things
like that that's not necessarily
micro management okay so so i only say
that because
you know i've definitely interviewed
people before that feel that they've
been micromanaged or had
feedback that we're micromanaging we're
actually
what we're trying to do is is prevent is
present data and statistics so that we
don't need to do that but because
lack of activity is being highlighted
you know people feel additional pressure
yeah that's very it's yeah you're i'm
glad you did that because it's a
it can be an easy thing to point at from
if you're not going to take
accountability yeah sure get that
so so if if we take that as the context
um look i i think there's a danger that
people are celebrating the wrong things
and the might and the mid managers maybe
are being managed themselves
like that you know maybe an awesome
month
is more about the cvs that have been
sent i mean i walked into a business um
uh i i walked into a business where
the sales floor uh were being managed
definitely
more on um the amount of cvs they sent
the amount
spent the amount of time they spent on
the phone and if i went up to any one of
them and asked what their
um what their target was in terms of
their
their uh you know their billing target
they were less clear on that
but they knew that they had to do this
and this you know calls and tvs
um you know and you know so look
that's not that's that's the other
extreme it's not healthy
yeah no okay uh interesting
so i guess how how
in your sort of journey then rory how
involved
i'm assuming that you would have been
but like how involved have you been in
sort of hiring for the teams that you've
managed and
and the businesses you've been involved
in yeah a lot so
um yeah at all levels so
um uh so i think
yeah i can think of a number of examples
where we've hired either associate
directors or directors
um at a senior level um
hired uh within operations too so
whether
across finance and hr or all the way all
the way through to entry level
you know i i enjoy
um vetting and selecting the talent
that will come into a company um
so yeah and answer your question quite a
lot
so let's so i'm just always because as
i'm sure you'll be aware and
it would have been a pain that you would
have experienced but
obviously yeah the the sort of ironic
challenge of
sort of finding it difficult to recruit
for your own recruitment business right
yeah i guess i don't know what have been
some of your biggest learns
when sort of fighting and wrestling
through that challenge of hiring for the
teams and businesses that
you um have hired for people want to
know like
what is it that you've ended up i know
there'll be no nuances to each business
and team that you recruit for but like
what are the actual sort of fundamentals
that that you always look for
in in the people when when hiring for
the teams that you you've been involved
in or hiring for them
that's what people want to know and it's
beyond the yeah they need to be
hard-working and these types of things
you know i mean it's
people want to know i don't know what
have ended up being the sort of real
core ingredients
you end up always trying to find in
people when hiring for the businesses
that you work for
yeah okay um look there's a sense of um
ambition
that has to exist as i said earlier this
job is is too hard
i think for people starting out
particularly but doesn't matter where
you are
uh in your journey it's kind of what's
next you know what why are you in it
you know what you know and is that
tangible how will you know when you get
there
um so they're working towards something
um for me it's also um
i think there's always a danger when you
uh or when people try and hire in their
own image
i think um one of the great things um
uh to try and do is is is you hire
people that might bring something
a little bit different you know it's
either a different approach or from a
different background or um or maybe
their hobbies are slightly different
um but they're just bringing different
they're bringing something that you
haven't got already i mean if you're if
you're hiring in numbers then obviously
you're gonna
you know you're gonna get some overlap
um
but i think the main thing is people
with ambitions people have
proved some form of achievement and
commitment
okay they've either stuck at something
or they've made something work or in
their own time they've achieved
something so some sense of achievement
really simply and a sense of where they
want to go next i think is
is at a base level and would you would
you be prepared to go out with them i
used to work with a i used to
work with a director whose acid test was
would you go with it would you go for a
drink with them or not
yeah it's like well yeah i guess
that that's not a bad starting point um
yeah
so yeah okay no yeah i just
yeah i find that i think you're you i
really like the
because you always hear hear sort of
culture fit don't you but you're talking
about culture out there aren't you
and yeah culturally i think that culture
thing is is potentially quite dangerous
look
you don't want people um who are going
to react against stuff all the time i've
actually been that person before where
i've
kind of reacted against and i've done it
for the right reasons to try and make
something better
um but actually that's not necessarily
helpful but you want people yeah
definitely culture ad it's an evolution
it's not
your culture at any one point surely
isn't a destination you know it's part
of the journey
yeah i love that and then this sort of
sort of goes into this slightly
a bit more on the sort of uh entry
or sort of early on um part of a
recruiter's journey but again it's
another
question that i got in my inbox which
was basically
you've been involved in you've had some
real solid experience in building teams
and
developing people and these types of
things so i guess yeah
the question was like how have you in
the past or continue at the moment
how do you help recruiters that maybe
early on in their journey
cope with doubting themselves but how
how do you actually
help recruiters break through those so
that those periods of where yeah they
may not believe or have the confidence
that
they can do this job and these types of
things that was just one of the
questions which i think
can sometimes be a big reason as to why
yeah the
the sort of turnover or why people leave
recruitment um
yeah just an interesting question i had
actual advice around that
and and i think i think one of the key
things there hashem is is that
is that perspective that someone is
taking you know um
trying to encourage someone to look at a
a longer-term perspective rather than
you know however bad their current
situation is they're probably looking at
a week or they've had a deal drop out or
they can't
can't get any interviews or you know
those are all these are all things that
you can work with
you know if if someone has the desire
and the will to make a success of it
you can work with that you know the
skill is just stuff you learn
you know and people will learn it at
different rates but you'll learn it
and and if there's a if there's a
particular area to to to adapt to work
with
you know we can do that over a period of
time um that the key thing it all comes
back into well why
why did you know what was your purpose
for coming into this in the first place
let's try and reconnect with that
you know yeah just because it's not
working right here and now
you know especially in the current
climate that's no reason to suggest that
you won't make a career
at a recruitment you know i was i was
pretty good as
a recruiter i was no way the best you
know
but i probably had that determination
and desire
just to stick at it and keep on going
and and trying to learn stuff along the
way
yeah no great and and then sort of find
the final piece on this which i i find
uh really interesting
uh because i'm speaking to more and more
businesses about it so i've spoken to
a number of recruiting agencies over the
last few months who felt who felt like
again the sort of impact positive impact
of
the sort of last 12 months is that it
has enabled
recruiters to sort of be more open to
their like spending time on their own
development yeah and personal
development
yeah so i guess one of the questions
that i had and
what someone sort of sent me was around
like
how to one as a recruitment business
owner or a manager i may
feel really passionate about that i
think sort of people my team
should adopt like we should have a
learning culture right that's something
that i believe that we should have
so i guess in your experience and in
your journey like how
how have you impacted and have you
impacted
sort of um the culture to be more of a
learning culture and
encourage how how can people get
recruiters to encourage
spending time on their own development
like how have companies
done this and impacted that
um i think that's a really really good
question um and i think often
uh people in our industry
um are searching for
and and it comes up in reviews or
something i want i want development but
but sometimes when you channel into that
it's like well what is that what is
development and what
and and that's not always clear there's
just that sense of well if you develop
me i'll get better
so i think you've just got to get clear
on what what are the things that are
going to really make a difference
and and for me there's a clear
distinction between
sales training recruitment training and
there are some awesome recruitment
trainers out there
are you just trying to get better at the
art of recruitment i call it an arts i'm
sure people outside recruitment
necessarily call it an art but you know
it is it is you know it
it's if you do it well um it is an art
you know
some people will have better conversion
ratios than others
therefore they're doing something
differently that is stuff you can learn
okay
um for me the big difference is
is when you start taking that away and
you start looking at managing
people in terms of you're trying to get
in their head a bit you're managing
their mental state you're managing their
perspective
um recruitment sounds like a really
cheesy line but
for me recruitment you win or lose in
your head
you know if you are if you are channeled
if you are working an
environment um that is there to support
and promote what you do
um if you are getting the investment
and and your and your mind is together
you are you are game on then
you know nine times out of ten you'll do
well so
and a lot of that but we don't really
start with that
um that sort of coaching uh sort of
almost like executive coaching really we
don't
start people on that journey until they
put their hand up for some kind of
management or leadership type role that
that's the bit
that is really worth investing in for me
a because you're shaping careers you're
giving people an opportunity to advance
themselves but also actually
they're learning stuff that is outside
recruitment that is still really
relevant within recruitment
um that's interesting so
i guess as we sort of come towards the
end
end here it'd be great to just talk a
bit about
the things that the common things that
you've been seeing with the people
you've been working with
and these types of things so i guess
like i said in in in the introduction
it seems like what you're trying to help
a lot of people with now is to sort of
fulfill their potential
yeah so i guess i'm maybe we're talking
a bit about here this little mindset
which is
what you may boil it down to but what do
you think
a lot of the time prevents i don't know
recruitment leaders
business owners or just teams in general
in recruitment
sort of stop them from holding back from
fulfilling their potential do you think
what what do you continue to see
and have continued to see over the last
six seven months
since you've been supporting people so
so i found this bit really interesting i
mean the great thing about working in a
consultancy role is you you just get
exposed to different businesses and you
and obviously you're not the competition
so
so it's great to be able to slice open a
business and and just be able to
to look at hey the stuff that they do
really well but also the stuff that
needs work
it tends to come down to different
things i i think sometimes
um if we if we work at the top down
so owners i think um or business leaders
often find it difficult to step back
from the detail and and look at the
broader play
so whether they're in a billing role um
in competition with their other in
competition with their other billers
um you know that that's quite a common
situation for for businesses up to a
certain size
and i use an analogy there of i don't
know do you ever follow american
football or anything like that yeah
yeah i do okay so american football so
quick analogy here
so american football you'll know that
you get that line of scrimmage you get
an offensive line you get a defensive
line and the offensive line is obviously
just trying to protect
their quarterback from the defensive
line so they're both in the they're both
in
the push yeah okay the danger
with that with that leading by example
uh
leader is that they're in the line of
scrimmage with everyone else so they're
they're doing the pushing and the
shoving
the danger there is when they flip the
ball back to the quarterback there's no
one there so there's no one actually
taking a more strategic view calling a
longer term play
um you know spotting the moves executing
the throw and completing the move and
therefore you all move up the pitch you
know you're stuck in that moment
so yeah for owners sometimes it's a
question of
giving themselves the space to take a
couple of steps back
you know with that ball and look at the
opportunities that exist
beyond the day beyond that week beyond
that month
and actually therefore they're investing
time in the opportunities for the people
in their business
so and again if you're in that line of
scrimmage you're not doing it you're not
doing it just to stay put you want to
move up the pitch
so although it's great that leadership
by example
i'm billing like everyone else and and i
totally get that businesses up to a
certain
size and scale you need to be doing that
there is also an obligation on a leader
to be able to take a step back and look
at the bigger picture i guess that's
what i'm trying to say
next level down is is is really in that
management tier of of combining their
own
billing performance and not becoming
almost too much of the quarterback
so almost going look 70 80 of your time
needs to be on your own billing
so imagine you're in a boat it's you and
you know two or three others that's your
team
every every time you're taking you're
the best rower in the boat
every time you're taking your hands off
yours and helping others out the boat's
going to grind to a halt
so you need to maximize that 20 30
you're spending with your team but
maintain focus on what you're doing so
it's a completely different dynamic
and then for for recruiters themselves
again it's a little bit it's a little
bit of mind space while you're doing it
reconnecting with your journey and your
purpose
but also actually holding it holding
yourself to account as much as possible
staying outcome orientated
but putting in the hard yards are gonna
you know
based on your own conversion ratios um
to enable you to actually to hit those
outcomes earn the cash progress
whatever your motivation is set up that
bar in southern spain
you know whatever it is so that you're
you're able to progress and move on so
i guess in a really kind of elaborate um
way we come back to it's about everyone
playing to position
and i think that's where it gets that's
where it gets a bit muddled hashem is
when
you get people who are either
uncomfortable in their position or they
only know one way of working
or the situation has kind of pushed them
into a different way of working or
or you know or a poor way of working
so yeah everyone playing to position
essentially is probably key
yeah and i love that that's really
interesting so look you've been in the
industry for for some time so i guess
again what you just
spoken about there is you've
been able to the last few months have um
yeah unique insight and obviously been
involved in
yeah different companies in the last few
years i guess
i don't know when i say to you the
future of the recruitment industry or
what what sort of companies are doing
really well that you think will enable
them to maximize their potential
what comes up for you
um so i think that companies that
that do well um are those that have
uh a really clear sense of vision and
purpose
um they're able to get staff on the
journey whatever that whatever the
circumstances
you know and i think um there are those
you know there are certain companies
that i think will see that there are
there'll be winners and looners losers
through this um coronavirus
um especially the kind of the working
from home piece
if you get your staff on the journey and
then if you're investing
in your middle management to gain the
game the scale and i think
if you if you really cut it down into
simple
segments if a company has a great
proposition they're really clear on what
they're offering is to market
you know and they're really clear what
that proposition means for the people
that work for them
if they've got the right people in the
right seats and they're also clear about
future seats that are available to them
and you're developing those people and
then if you have the right processes in
place to ensure
that your people have every chance of
making a success of their career
and they're supported you know that's
fundamental too so
great proposition awesome people uh or
people with potential
and good processes i think those those
are the things for me that that for me
if i'm ever looking at a business
those are the three key things that i
would look at to try and gauge
you know the sort of impact if any that
i could have on a that i could have on a
company
love that so i've got five final
questions for you
before i finish okay okay all right so
first one easy one first one
is if you could change the industry
what would you improve oh my word um
okay what a slight frustration i have
and maybe i'm a bit of a purist here
but a slight frustration i have is is
that a lot of recruitment
is becoming increasingly transactional
and that the skills
of recruiters are being driven more or
the role of a recruiter is being driven
more
towards administration so i receive a
role over a portal
you know i use linkedin to find a
candidate i match them and then i'm just
going to sit there and cross my fingers
i might organize a few interviews along
the way
but let's hope we've got a deal i i
would like to see recruiters
if if i could you know um change
something
uh step up in terms of um
professionalism and partnership
um and i would love to see recruiters
have more confidence more pride in what
they do
um and look to influence through that
process
i i always use a a mantra of three
things i think the
most important thing for any recruiter
is to be memorable okay
but in order to do that um for me it's
be relevant
be niche be valued you know be relevant
be contemporary you're working markets
that are adding real value
okay be niche be an expert in what you
do
and be valued you know it's not just
about bum on the seat yes you need to do
that really effectively
but be more than that be a partner and i
think if i could change the sector
that that's what i would try and that's
what i would try and achieve
of course my second question is
what what book have you read that has
had the biggest impact on you
if you're not a reader that could be a
podcast or an audio book that you listen
to but yeah
oh podcasts obviously
um so i i don't
usually go for the for the business
books in a major way but actually
um during the lockdown
period and this sort of extended period
with coronavirus
um i i have read a few of them and i
think the one
uh that has resonated most with me
um is by matthew syed who who
writes to the sunday times he he has a
book called rebel ideas
and um it's it's the power of
uh what it would have been i can't even
speak what it's basically
talking about is the power of
diversity and not necessarily from
an ethnic or a gender perspective
although that's certainly part of it
but it's it's the power of having people
with different perspectives and
different
insight different backgrounds different
influences in a room
making a decision or trying to create a
solution to a problem
rather than um what i've certainly seen
in the past which is
people in the room are all very similar
they all think the same way
you know there's um no confrontation
there's no conflict it's all about
agreement and
and just getting behind the leader and
going yeah great idea
um so yeah rebel rebel ideas by matthew
side i think is
really really good and he uses some
great examples um
in there about how that has um you know
how that diversity element has helped
come to better decisions
nice so slightly different one here
one what did you spend your first
biggest commission paycheck on
god you know as you've said this has
been a long
journey for me and struggling to think
back that far uh
um look my my
you know back in the day there were a
bunch of us uh this is in the mid 90s
now
where we just wanted to earn i think the
key target was we all just wanted to win
a hundred thousand pounds
yeah and back back in those days if you
if you take inflation year on year
it's probably 200 grand now okay yeah um
that that was we were just gunning for
that um and i remember the guy who got
there first
he was very very good uh and so so
yeah we that's what we all wanted to do
i
i'm not sure there was anything i don't
remember going out and splashing out
on on anything i've never really been
into into watches or cars and things
like that
but i do think i it probably got me on
the property ladder so i
i got my first flat um
bearing in mind i joined recruitment i
was 25 i got my first flat at 27.
oh amazon well i didn't own it outright
to be fair
but i had a really chunky deposit down
on it
um and that probably enabled me to then
you know move fairly quickly at the
housing ladder and it was probably that
you know if i hadn't been for
recruitment i would have never been able
to do that i mean
you know so you know if you get this
right it can it can change your life so
um i'm afraid that that's probably not a
very you'd probably expect a far more
exciting uh anecdote than that
just turning it into putting it into a
flat probably not we had in mind but
that's
i think that's probably what i did no
getting on the property ladder
is quite a popular one so yeah final
question is
uh yeah i guess it's still sort of
relevant but i guess
my final question always is so what
what's the ultimate goal for your
recruitment career now so that could be
yeah what's the ultimate goal for your
career now
all right okay look i'm still passionate
about this sector
um and uh you know i really
uh enjoy the potential that it gives my
perspective
if i can be if i can be part of you know
another or a few more um
really impressive growth stories and if
i can look in another five
ten years at people specifically leaders
that i've just helped
shape along the way um you know
that would be a great glass of wine to
maybe reflect on that
and um and look at and look at those
individuals and and hopefully you know
as i said you know being part of being
part of a growth thing i i
i fell out of love with the with the
with the corporate world for me it's
always been about
almost supporting the underdog of taking
something with huge potential
and growing it and i i think yeah i've
got another 10 years of doing that
amazing it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you thank you
no thank you very much good